trailers trailers keep on coming and now
we got the Merc with the mouth so the
first real official release of a
Deadpool trailer has finally happened
this has been a long time coming because
first it was the test footage that got
leaked and then finally got revealed
properly that was from a year ago then
there was the footage for out of
comic-con which again got leaked now we
have an official release and I'm not
entirely sure if this trailer is the
exact same thing that was shown at Comic
Con I think it's pretty close I don't
think it's the exact same thing though
in any case this is our first proper
look at Deadpool in a proper release
from the movie itself we've gotten some
very interesting and some very good
teaser material up to this point but
this is the first thing that we've
really gotten a good look at what's
gonna be in the film itself and it's
good but I'm not quite as thrilled as I
kind of wanted to be with this there's
not really anything wrong with it the
bits of humor that we get are good i
like you know the kind of meta shoutouts
to ryan reynolds having been green
lantern and that not working out well at
all I like just the tone in the attitude
of Deadpool but i'm not particularly in
love with how much of the trailer's
taken up with action and in particular
looks like really just one main action
set piece set on the highway now maybe
that just largely has to do with where
they are in terms of post-production
maybe that's the stuff that's just most
ready to show so that's what they put
the most of in this trailer but the
thing was I was never worried about the
action for this action movies they went
through a rough period where everything
was shaky cam and all of that you know
rapid cuts they got bad for a while but
action movies and action sequences have
gotten in a good place that was never
what I was worried about what I wanted
to see more of was the humor and just
how whacked-out Deadpool is as a
character especially considering that
one of the trailers that was released
was a red band I kind of hoped for a bit
more of that and really just see how
irreverent and off-the-wall this guy is
and I feel like they held back on that a
little bit I suspect and I hope
that it was deliberate because they're
really trying to get the general
audience on board with this because I
mean the fan fans were gonna go to this
no matter what they've got us in their
pocket so they made something a little
bit safer with this trailer I think in
an attempt to make it appeal to a wider
audience than the folks who are already
on board I mean that said while I I
don't like that the action is fat is
featured so heavily in this trailer the
action that is in there is good i like
it i like how nimble and fluid
Deadpool's motions are and the way he
moves through the year the way he fights
it feels like legit actions they hits
they look like good solid hits weathers
from a gunner from punch I still think
Ryan Reynolds is perfect for this part
what happened to this character in x-men
origins what we really felt like one of
the most wasted opportunities that were
they are definitely correcting that here
but again I just I don't like the fact
that the trailer overall feels a bit
generic it reminds me to a certain
extent of the first ant-man trailer
where there are hints of what the movie
actually is but the actual sort of
thrust of the trailer or the way they
frame it and what they put the emphasis
on is a bit more on the generic side
kind of focusing on the action in both
cases and not so much putting the
emphasis on what really makes this
unique in the superhero film now I'm
kind of hoping that much like with an
man that is more an indication of the
marketing then of the finished product
cuz I still have a pretty good amount of
faith in this thing that it's going to
be as nuts and off the wall and
irreverent and meta as I want it to be
and I don't usually get this level of
confidence in a man of property that
really hasn't proven itself at all but I
I really do have a high degree of
confidence in this and I do suspect that
my reservations with the trailer are
just reflective of the marketing and not
of the finished film I still expect to
really enjoy the heck out of this film
so have you seen the Deadpool trailer
right band I hope if you've seen any of
them but in any case what were your
thoughts on the thing whatever it was
drop something down in the comments and
let's talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned
you